[Music]
an interesting name news Oh interesting
submitted by Karen from Pomona
California loves yeah hey what's up
Kevin let me Ramona you have conventions
there the name of a new restaurant is
causing a stir in Long Beach [ __ ]
yellow ding dongs yellow fever oh no no
it's owned by [ __ ] Asians do be more
pissed yeah is it yellow fever mean you
want [ __ ] agents
am I crazy it's that and it's also a
disease for you get from whiskey or
something oh yeah yeah it's not a good
yeah it's like jungle fever I have
yellow fever huh a lot of people are
upset about fetishizing fetishizing
right fetishizing sure ok anyway
Fettuccine very cheesy size fetish
fetish I know that Isis I hiked on that
issue who are the [ __ ] asses that are
[ __ ] you know what's so funny is
because this [ __ ] is it's so bit
backfired on the offended [ __ ]
cuz it's owned by an Asian girl like
it's not it's [ __ ] old I want to be
better size that you want people parity
goosing [ __ ] you what the [ __ ] it's a
peridot it's a parody size it's a
[ __ ] parity it you know like what
does it move the owner God Oh cold Karl
mom balls I love it I know she rocks
this any time a female shaves her head I
know of this business anymore and gij
forget amber was perfecto Rose is it
rose known amber rose the other
amber Rose's ball too yeah my amber oh
yeah Briana you nailed it
as usual you know Muriel has been here
before the tattoos the [ __ ] she's
super hot Oh Rover that Rose chick that
everyone loves everyone's like oh I
would I would want I'm not a lesbian but
I will come up an MMA fighter strike at
the go to Dragon Tattoo no the other
ones who from the prison show we're
spending way
nobody [ __ ] cares anymore hey okay
looks like Angela Joycelyn she's not
rose anyway no idea who the [ __ ] that is
sugar free Ganges Angelina Jolie's like
little sister I am so good right
anyway I was a lot of hard work for
[ __ ] worthless information
wait you google or you're gonna be glad
that you did Google amber Rose's bald
ruby roses novel that's what I've been
saying but you're the one that said
amber rose and I said yes I know I did I
forgot who she met and that person is
not bald
this change she has like dentist her she
is not I don't know what else to call it
that's like my pompadour but [ __ ] right
which is in the tonic - yeah she's in
John Wayne - she's the one where every
time she's talking like oh you're nude
act yeah yeah or enjoy the new black
good vibe
no she was not another TV show before
that bill does in our boat went viral
because she was really hot anyway she's
hot she's hot she's hot
hey thank you cuz you you thought a lot
of people that we thought were hot we're
not hot musicians actresses actors that
Britney in her prime was not hot blast
Simpson Britney in her prime I like
don't even like white [ __ ] but damn
she was she was 1999 Brittany this guy
was like Christina Aguilera back in the
day I like Christine Aguilar 2001 you
monster on no no I like just unfuckable
he wanted Jessica's yeah that's the one
I wanted but I don't know I like I like
my memory of her story about Jessica
Simpson was the hottest Britney -
deena Christina Aguilera wasn't as hot
like in genie in a bottle because I the
last memory is the Moulin Rouge when I
was like you got dirty you like Pirates
of the Caribbean and then when I look
back at the crystal uh congenial bottle
I was like oh yeah she's yeah she looked
like a little younger net like that for
me but you like I'm young we all know
that yep I like them young let's get
back to this story here though a lot of
people you started it a no idea that's
right I didn't like Britney Spears cuz
she looks like she has the it's the
opposite of up syndrome okay I don't
know but you know sometimes like there's
like Katie Holmes has this we're like
the eyes look like this
that's what I'm saying she had the
goldfish look so like some there's
certain girls that have this look and a
Britney Spears Katie Holmes can't do it
you wait Katie Holmes are you guys crazy
I guess what did I like those girls I
don't care I don't give a [ __ ] off that
Britney Spears was bad as [ __ ] no but
don't mind it so for example one person
that I grew a acquired taste for was
Anne Hathaway also had the up syndrome
know she does it's just some big eyes
eyes and then later on I found out ya
dishes hot afterwards okay the way
there's some nice ass kitties that's
probably we won't have the way yes who's
that share puppies are the nicest
Hollywood titties out there you see the
one that was okay any woman it's the
white cat woman she was going you can
say let's talk about this and you got
caught no yeah that's yokai watch she's
the new cowboy princess diary
yeah yeah you girls who have yellow
fever are you guys cool with this
restaurant I don't give a [ __ ] cuz I'm
not Asian I have the old favor can I
thank you
you got 50% yo that's good then you got
brown feed gotta get some you got beans
because you've got beta and switched
always forget that all of you guys are
your ethnicity that's true I don't
look you guys know I always forget that
you're Asian yeah that's true I don't
see color I just see ugly I don't see
color that's what I'm saying I see ugly
people like oh not you guys I'm just
saying like that's ugly that's ugly you
know that's why when we see criminals
and [ __ ] the first thing I do is like
that [ __ ] wrong there you know
like that's what I noticed I noticed
ugly more than anything yeah so yellow
fever here they have three locations but
they recently opened this one that's
inside of a 365 by Whole Foods and so
they Whole Foods tweeted this out and
that's when [ __ ] hit the fan
Whole Foods should tweet out [ __ ] egg
[ __ ] why are they shaming [ __ ] and eggs
Whole Foods are done they're not shaming
it they're just saying it's a new
restaurant they're just like yo check
this new restaurant just opened at one
of our locations pretty much thank you
yeah I was gonna say of course the
widest grocery store I think something's
no what kind of food do they serve Asian
bowls yeah it's it's kind of like fusion
Korean stuff and it's like a healthy
twist to it
and if they got a bunch of different
bowls I saw pictures it looks good I
feel like grand foods already pretty
helpful but even healthier well I think
they got like bowls with quinoa and all
these different options and stuff yeah I
might I might have saw something
different but I do remember just bowls
and it looked like that healthy look
what's what's well what are what are
people saying okay people are very let's
let's give these [ __ ] attention let's
do it I I do want them to be heard
[ __ ] [ __ ] um yeah some people
just need their fall sacks to drop a
little bit yeah a lot of people were
just upset because of the name obviously
so they're just like you know what she
owns the word though she's a [ __ ]
Asian female she could say where the
[ __ ] she could say yellow fever
you know she owns that [ __ ] that's like
rappers on the n-word that's they're
sure that it's not racist
so she's fanny white and then she's also
saying like plus it grabs your attention
like if we were called I forgot her
example but some traction
changing bowls like if it's Asian bowls
and you're gonna just drive right by it
and not even blink but this that's like
I got the yellow fever I need to get
that bowl again all it's so good I mean
she's awesome like it's just the color
to us like it's just yellow
you know why are Asians called yellow
the yellow man in the lens I don't
because we had jaundice I don't know I
don't know you know what it is though
like you know just to be completely
Frank it's because like they're trying
to do like this [ __ ] called I call
it like comparative suffering you don't
mean so it's like well if black people
get to complain about that then that
means we shouldn't stand for this too
but it's like if we didn't have a
problem with it why the [ __ ] do we need
to have a problem with it now you know
what I mean and they're taking that as a
sign of weakness and it's not a sign of
weakness
I just think Asian people were above it
and they're still above it yeah I mean
so it's kind of like the dog barking at
the moon so somebody comes in they say
Oh Asian people that it's like bro
you're beneath me I don't even need to
connect with you like that that's how I
thought like Asian culture was anyways
you know it was I don't know what's
happening because the more Americanized
we become the more complaining exactly
because there's a lot of people that are
younger than us that hasn't been through
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's complain it's a
generational thing yeah and like might
like it's like my dad like he always
said it like this he goes whoa you know
I asked my deck of some away some people
coming there was he some racist [ __ ] he
goes why do I care maybe he goes exact
because I'm a business owner I don't the
business you have me so here it's
affected by this yeah he literally told
me it's literally like a poor man trying
to give me life advice who are you to
talk to me like that I can't even hear
ya
it's one of the Asian superpowers you
know like black people could jump really
high for Asians it's we're blind to the
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] to me don't affect me
is it like is it offensive to here like
it's like you know like in the westerns
it's like it's like what's the matter
you yellow never even heard of that you
never heard that leave me alone I heard
of you yellow-belly oh yeah I heard that
arabela bastard or like in fact we chose
yellow means
really I don't think it meant Asian
though back then like Yeller like yeah
yeah yeah yeah things are yellow like
golden retrievers bananas I don't care
yellow cars are cool yeah I mean I
wouldn't buy one like this restaurant
it's called cheek shop just I - I'd be
doubt that like it was one person
tweeted out dear yellow fever restaurant
oh stop with a deer [ __ ] your open
public letter you [ __ ] loser
continue dear diary if you're going to
name your restaurant yellow fever you
might as well open another - called me
love you a long time now could be dopes
awesome down with that me eat you long
time that's who's me so hungry uh who's
the person it's at rice daddy 700 rice
paddy seven that reminds me of these
like duo Asian youtubers that used to
get mad at other people making songs
about Asian food when they do it all the
time yes that's one and it's always some
young guy - he's his young guy who's
like just came out of college and he's
ready to tell the world why they got it
wrong rice daddy this is rice daddy Oh
get the [ __ ] out of here you look like a
satanic Chinese man he actually has a
lot of powers what how many followers is
yeah oh content does he do he has 50k
flowers he's an Asian American novelist
who doesn't shy from topics of race and
representation that your name is rice
paddy daddy seven yeah his name is
apparent this I also suck at math oh
that's real and then are you ready for
this [ __ ] like this guy is going there
like he's a [ __ ] ace like edgy comic
Panda Express is not real Chinese food
hashtag Asian Twitter no wow dude unless
you're a fan bro amen
that was edgy in my [ __ ] 1989 like
holy hell it's just a little I think
it's all [ __ ] he follows you David I
know as I'm saying unless you're a fan
bro that's why I said unless you're a
fan then he loves you and then I'm
saying like I understand where you're
coming from however your your Twitter
handle is a little odd for somebody it's
hypocritical if you're gonna talk about
hey don't use you know the whole yellow
thing you you should have called it me
love you long time
but then your name is rice in it it has
right it's like yeah and all the other
stuff I'm bad at math right like since
you says you follow me maybe you follow
me because you want to talk [ __ ] to me
but I don't really know but that that's
really not a good case I mean we're
gonna send so many more followers to
this dude he might be a good dude who
knows but that shit's gonna stop by
yellow fever first gear self a yummy
ball I don't know I like yellow fever
I'm gonna go support them and I think
[ __ ] more power to you own the word man
don't give it power [ __ ] bury that
word don't give is it negative if a girl
on like say tinder is like I only [ __ ]
Asian dudes like is that [ __ ] awesome
like to me yell fevers are saying I
understand yeah I just don't know either
yeah yeah if even even white guys that
that [ __ ] people might hate me for
this but if white guys want only Asian
girls are only black girls or whatever
who the [ __ ] cares why people give a
[ __ ] about fetish like why you got a
fetish sighs whatever that's like that's
like who the [ __ ] cares why do you care
well everyone's a little it's like
everyone pushes like what's your
preference you're allowed to have a
preference everyone's got a preference
and then if you say your preference it's
like yo you can't have a preference
because yeah crazy yeah I mean like why
the [ __ ] I like [ __ ] nice ass like
what why does that why does that matter
yeah I mean that's a beautiful quality
be in cursive somewhere